hello welcome to week interview with me
Jane second Kevin Maguire and Andrew
Pierce are here to look back at the
biggest stories of the past seven days
before we get started let's get a taste
of what the week was all about on the
world stage in Davos Prince Andrew
publicly denied claims from a woman that
he had sex with her while she was
underage no Iraq report before the
election the Chilcott inquiry will
publish its long-awaited findings after
the 7th of May Tony Blair denied Sky
News uncovered a secret government file
detailing allegations of historical and
natural sexual behavior by MPs in
Westminster while the Home Secretary at
the time of the allegations Leon Brittan
died Islamic state revealed they were
holding two Japanese hostages demanding
a ransom of 200 million dollars
the terror group was one of the topics
and Barack Obama's State of the Union
address to the nation the son claimed
they had a mammary lapse after
publishing a picture of a topless woman
just days after media outlets reported
page three had been dropped
cigarettes may be sold in plain
packaging the government's announced it
will press ahead with a vote to ban
branded packets Saudi King Abdullah who
was seen as a modernizing leader and
ally of the West died in hospital whilst
the Coronation Street actor and cook
bride passed away at the age of 60 she
played Deirdre Barlow in the soap for 14
years three significant deaths this week
but anchor bride's death I think been
felt by a lot of people when people
would remember most of all completely
unexpected I hadn't even realized she'd
been ill I must have met her watch
coronation watch a few years in his
happening rich wasn't in the program ill
but I grew up with that woman me too I
was a teenager she was on Coronation
Street we lived through our weddings and
a catastrophes and their relationships
with Ken and very very sad for her
family
and all the cast and crew yeah more
people watched her wedding to Ken Barlow
than watched
Diana and Charles your your hero boring
bites on the death of it I get the rest
Corey Zehner no okay also
Abdulla he also passed away we said you
know seen as a reformed inky humming
that isn't the concept that's in the
context headings women can't drum if you
wouldn't be on the telly dress like that
you'd be a chattel of some man cool
reformer right you here's a reform it
makes you wonder what's coming next
okay so let's take a look at the stories
that you've chosen for us this week and
up first the week the world's rich and
powerful descend on the Swiss town of
Davos Oxfam warned that global
inequality is on the app and that the
world's richest 1% will soon account for
half of all global wealth
Alex Rossi has the figures if you've got
the money these are the kinds of things
you could splash the cash on and
according to Oxfam the wealthiest 1%
will soon be able to gobble up even more
of these symbols of status the charity
claims the uber rich are getting much
richer leaving the rest of the world's
population behind in the global wealth
stakes we think the prospects are very
bleak and I think it's scary not just
for poor people but for rich people too
that's why it's in the interests of
everybody that we reach if you like pink
inequality as soon as possible and start
going back in the other direction
Oxfam claims its research shows that 1%
of people in the world now have 48
percent share of global wealth and it
says that share will increase to half by
next year the Oxfam research though has
been widely criticised by concentrating
on the rich some economists say the
report ignores the fact that global
poverty in many parts of the world is
actually falling Oxfam is now turning
its attention to the World Economic
Forum in Davos it's calling on the
world's leaders to act now and narrow
what it claims is the growing gulf
between rich and poor Alex points out
there that more people are coming out of
poverty should we care that the rich are
getting richer it's typical skewed
propaganda by Oxfam which is
increasingly being taken over by class
war left-wing warriors actually what
Oxfam should be caring about more is
poverty that's what they're there for
and the statistics show massively since
1990
to 2015 the number of people living at
whether it's on a pound today has fallen
for around forty eight percent to twenty
two there's been a massive drop and I
suspect as the world gets richer and
we're all getting wealthier the middle
classes that were getting wealthier the
poor are getting wealthier the if there
is a trickle down even a torrent effect
with the poor they shouldn't they
shouldn't be so skewed themselves hello
to propaganda for the filthy rich there
of course of course are fewer people in
absolute power there are huge changes in
China Latin America they're a
revolutionary motor movements going
through being far more equitable but I
think there is something deeply
unpleasant in a world where 1% will soon
own as much as either 99% in Britain
you've got five families who own as much
as 12 million people and I think it was
George Orwell who said that if you put a
bomb under the West Stand of twickenham
you'd have said back British fascism 20
years I wouldn't want to do that in
Dallas but I wouldn't mind all being
snowed in for 20 years and let's see
what would hurt the global world
actually we're now back to the figures
way we were in 2002 and nothing changed
under its law any 13 years just because
somebody can now have a sip of water and
doesn't die of thirst doesn't mean
that's the end of it you want you I
wouldn't give a penny to Oxfam some
right-wing horrible group as you rightly
do let's move on to another guest at
Davos and he was drawing the media
crowds of course and that was Prince
Andrew he went to boost British business
but did a great address allegations that
he slept with an underage girl firstly I
think I must want for the record to
refer to the events that have taken
place in the last few weeks
and I just wished to reiterate and to
reaffirm the statements which have
already been made on my behalf by
[ __ ] Palace my focus is on my work
should he have gone Kevin no I mean look
at that
so wouldn't I can't believe he does that
much for British business what's it what
cease focus focus on his work he's
skiing golfing three B's helicopter ride
and stayin outta court actually they're
far enough they still get him to travel
abroad a lot because he is effective in
certain parts of the world where
democracies turn particularly flourish
and talk about Azerbaijan the arab
kingdoms where they like talking to
people like Prince Andrew because he's
one of them and if he is still good for
business what's wrong with that I do
agree with Kevin though that performance
in Davos was painful to watch because
that was him actually saying I didn't do
it but he's been lawyers have crept all
over the statement but of course he
couldn't appear in that forum without at
least alluding to it and it's an
unprecedented thing for a member of the
royal family to publicly address that
sort of allegation because he is not
actually the subject of these court
papers he's just mentioned in them so he
doesn't have a legal framework on which
to defend yeah he's in a difficult
position because of his terrible bad
judgement in hanging around with Jeffrey
Epstein a billionaire hedge fund
convicted sex fiend in the in the u.s.
that's why I use in trouble it's
completely of his own making any
deserves no sympathy whatsoever my
sympathy is for the people who are
complaining a legend despite his denials
that he exploited them well I don't have
a problem with him mixing with
billionaires but he should not have
continued his friendship with Epstein
when he knew he was convicted of sex
with underage girls okay right now we
don't we have a gaffe of the week about
this time but this week we've got a
bust-up of the week and it is all about
class or class depending on how you say
it I suppose that belies a lot of about
how you view it the Labour MP Kris
Bryant and the singer James Blunt of
exchange blows after the shadow arts
minister said culture shouldn't be
dominated by the likes of Eddie Redmayne
James Blunt and their ilk all privately
educated of course a blunt then attacked
the MP for envy based vote hunting
he called him a classist [ __ ] and the
prejudiced Wazza will be getting your
definitions of those later but does he
have a point does Chris Brian have a
point there too many poor shows doing
one in the arts well he'd know all about
poor shows because of course he went to
Cheltenham College and they I checked
the cope the fees currently for
Cheltenham College even man who I would
balk with this thirty three thousand
pounds a year so and that of course
helped Chris Bryant get into Oxford
which is full of privileged Wessex I
have no doubt and you're never going to
win an argument if you're a about the
Glenda Jackson ray when Ron is a very
successful actor in this country and
actually stop knocking people you should
just rejoice in the fact we've got
actors whether they were educated in a
comprehensive like I was or Eton who are
up for Oscars and Baptists celebrate it
don't attack it look miserable class war
he must have been talking to Maguire God
defend the indefensible yet again now of
course I think it's hilarious bus stop
and look poor people control about
poverty he had a good education a
private education he can talk about the
impact and it's true that there does
seem to be too many people from private
schools who are coming through now Keira
Knightley as an exception she went to
comprehensive in in southwest London but
James Blunt is incredibly thin skin it's
a it's a it's a wonderful reaction and
if his parents wasted 30 grand a year
Ronnie's education at Harrow which is
really for exactly he just think so now
was just the same as going to bash
Street come on James you know grow up
and accept look around you and see the
divisions in Britain well the bus stops
of another kind and this week a lot of
coverage of the Sun newspaper after page
three girls were covered up and then
back on show after almost a week without
nipples it looked like the red top's
might have given in to the no more page
three campaign but on Thursday we saw
only call 22 from Bournemouth that how
do you this has been handled it seems to
have gone they didn't say it was
officially gone the time said it was
gone their sister paid well that's when
we heard the time said its finish you
thought there's obviously some corporate
companies strategy here there isn't a
strategy there is it is a shambles but I
say look I'm not interested in paying
never have been don't surprise me funny
that
actually I could and I couldn't care
less
although I think it's outdated but I
don't think it's meaning women well they
don't have to do it no women well next
to you Oh Glenn you know you're sitting
there anyways to notice later I don't
think people do all my kids at some
stage we get there you get the son of
home like the other papers and they've
all point out why is that woman there
why you know they don't say the sexual
object objectification of that woman but
they ask him why is there and I think
they've handled it really badly and I
think the sons got a lot better recently
I think David dinsmoor's a very good
editor when they say in The Times
another another paper and that's stable
that it's gone you believe it The Times
has been humiliated by bringing it back
they had all that thanks for the
mammaries stuff which was really funny
if you're aged thirteen burn otherwise
not and I just think you get all the
Girl Guides and women's dance do all
those groups are criticizing them that
criticizing them but there are some
people who who back page three we've
been speaking some of their loyal
readers you know some without phase
three that's not gonna be the son
anymore is it
I think it's the right for a one-twos if
she wants to get boobs out what do you
know yeah somewhat charge it now yeah
wasn't the world changed yeah for the
worse right it's like for a quiz now can
you tell me what links these animals
there it is peacock Fox a chihuahua any
ideas I have uh-huh
you'll find out after the break
welcome back to week in review with me
Jane second Kevin Maguire associate
editor of The Daily Mirror's here and
consultant editor of The Daily Mail
Andrew Pierce also now before the break
we asked chaps what linked these items
Andrew says he knows these were the
characters in a poll by Lorde ask off
this Vikki are identify what animals
which leaders which leaders and which
ones do you think we've got Cameron yeah
I've got Faraj and we've got Clegg admit
van wasn't up there was Cameron Lee
peacock was Ono Cameron was the Fox
sorry Fox so Cameron was the fault yeah
Feroz was the peacock Clegg was the chew
out to our in David Cameron stop I
remember now
Miliband was the animal you wouldn't
bother going to see in a zoo well done
right we're going across the pond now
what President Obama announced this week
it's time for the u.s. to turn the page
on years of hardship as he made his
annual State of the Union address Tom
McGwire corn has more for Barack Obama
Capitol Hill is now enemy controlled
territory in both chambers of Congress
but this is a president bouncing back
from last year's political setbacks
because the US economy is recovering
America for all that we have endured for
all the grip and hard work required to
come back for all the tasks that lie
ahead know this the shadow of crisis has
passed and the State of the Union is
strong Washington's political gridlock
is again on full display but instead of
pleading for cooperation
this year Barack Obama taunted
Republicans daring them not to support
him there were light-hearted moments
mocking applause from Republicans and
affirm presidential put down I have no
more campaigns to run my only agenda
I know because I won both of them but
the focus was on the economy tax breaks
for the middle classes and higher taxes
the president wants to see on the rich
he knows that means a fight with
Republicans but hopes he's begun shaping
the battleground two years before the
election to choose his successor
whooping isn't there than you see in the
House of Commons you get a lot in the
House of Commons and waving all the
papers it can look stupid sometimes
other times it's just part of the
pantomime of it but he's a great speaker
a bottle one of the best I've I've heard
reinvigorated this speech seem to me
it's a lot more confident that he has
been but not happy not seen that
throughout the last six well it was on
the home straight now you see that that
you see it at the beginning you see it
at the end you kind of see it were prime
ministers as well you know they come in
all full of joy and get towards an
election they come up with him it's just
he's gonna pop off isn't he gonna do
something else
he's an historic figure in the United
States cuz he's the first black
president but I suspect with people who
voted for him both times we look back at
the end and think
did he really achieve things like
Guantanamo Bay this the great surge of
American life still they're still open
and he said he'd get rid of it the
president can't even do that great
disappointment to me and of course now
he's gonna propose a two hundred billion
pounds of tax increases on the rich by
closing their loopholes on bang goes to
help the middle classes and he's a great
admirer of David Cameron so at least I
should do that in Britain
no no but let's move on to your top
paper stories this week excuse me Kevin
let's kick off with you and it's a
birthday fine for a young boy this is
the five-year-old who failed to attend a
classmates party his parents later found
an invoice in his school bag that's
right that was Alex the the son was
Charlie skiing on a dry ski slope party
boy didn't go so the parents of the the
kid whose birthday will send this
invoice I I find it all very very sad
really
first of all they didn't go didn't say
he wasn't gonna turn up an invoice
actually printing it out properly making
it look official why can't they just
have a word I'm putting in the little
boys
satchel the teacher Lee the teacher
didn't know the teacher thought it was
another silly mother says she's going to
take to County Court you know I've got
kids at primary school and just the
thought of the atmosphere on the boy who
was never invited that's all changed now
go to your choice now and it's the issue
of Scottish boats on English laws Nicola
Sturgeon of course saying that Scottish
MPs they'll be especially keen to vote
on NHS trophy yeah well this is again
all part of her electioneering to see
off labour and north of the border the
next general election but if she's
serious about this this will be a
constitutional outrage because
traditionally the SME have avoided
trying to get involved in exclusively
English matters she's now saying the
opposite and there's a possibility of
course the SNP could be in coalition
with the Labour Party and it is now
causing real tension and legitimately
between England and Scotland and it's
putting more press than ever on labour
to agree to some form of deal on English
votes through resources the Tories say
they're going to do that labour won't
say that because of narrow disable and
that would disable labour even more
length of the border where they need
labor vote Labour's come up with the
proposals as far it's very different of
the torreón but they have come up with a
proposal but she's a very canny
political operator and Nicola Sturgeon
she wants labour to do battle south of
the border as well as north of the
border because she wants to weaken
labour so she can have a bigger voice
after the election fascinating stuff
well staying with politics and on to the
Greens next this week one of the other
polls that Lord Ashcroft carried out
suggested they'd get 11% of the vote but
what would they actually do if they were
in power and they're not what do you
feel about their policies and I think a
lot of people who you know my the greens
with their stance on environmental
issues perhaps haven't some of the
papers took great delight and flagging
them up this is the this is the monster
raving loon apart II with a respectable
face
tax the Green Party's plan for Beyonce
they're going to put soup attacks on big
artis who come and perform here they're
gonna put a tax on gift that's those who
don't who wouldn't be paying tax you
might buy your son or daughter a car
you're gonna have to pay a tax on that
but they're going to give every single
person in Britain rich or poor 71 pounds
50 paid for out of the public purse what
on earth is that about
but why don't why do we need that but
also make them pay for they're gonna
make the the minimum wage a living wage
of 10 pounds by 2020 that's 2 pounds
more than Labor's realized the railways
that's popular green should be in the
television debates y'all know they do
not want to achieve economic growth they
want flat economic growth because they
think economic growth is bad for the
economy bad for employment too yeah but
it can be you can share our world I can
defend I realize it's offend some of it
because some of it is right but of
course they will now be in the first two
debates if they go ahead but of course I
do think the broadcaster's are always
coming up with a system as gonna fail
because for instance the Democratic
unionists a tempies Northern Ireland 4th
biggest party in parliament they're
excluded now applied there in in the SNP
room ok time now to move on to your ups
and downs of the week Andrew we'll start
with you this week and new this week are
sending away Beyonce she'll be back
there in a moment you're sending up mark
Ryland I love the book Mantle's books I
can't stand the woman who wrote them
she's not I saw the stage version of
Wolf Hall and bring up the bodies and
now the TV production it's brilliant and
Mark Ryan it is absolutely great as
Thomas Cromwell sinister it was a little
dark but really really get good
I'd like chop and change too much
billing right so we're sending him up
who was sending down there Andrew almost
as old Tutankhamun
some cleaner they think not his beard
off and the [ __ ] at the Museum rather
than sending it away for lab to restore
this wonderful wonderful iconic thanks
put it on with being there in the B&B
Egyptian artifact the most famous
Egyptian artifact and they've stuck it
together with Evo stick given the way
they've been locking up Al Jazeera
journalists in Egypt I'm not surprised
the cleaner panicked right
so they said chin economy's going down
you're sending up there Kevin Deborah
Arnott this is sue the cigarette
packaging it is chief executive aren't
you smoking she's beaten big tobacco you
can you can snores all that way the end
of this program but she's she's one
getting plain packaging so good for her
so she's going up but you're sending
down Michael Gove and there is a Beyonce
link to this one isn't there well there
is because he is ringtone we when it
went off in cabinet we think was
irreplaceable but of course he's free
schools in Durham the ones being point
of special measures and others losing
funding
no wonder David Cameron decided he
wasn't irreplaceable at the ring won't
say which one do you think it was I
don't know any of her hit record so well
that going kids education events of the
week lost its schools re spending this
week do you know and you don't like Wolf
Hall Beyonce fat thank you both very
much thank you for joining us for our
review of the week don't forget you can
catch Kevin and Andrew in action on the
sky knees press preview along with your
the paper reviewers as they take a first
look at the day's papers every evening
at 10:30 and 11:30 on Sky News it will
be back for more next week 7 now it's
goodbye from them
your bye and it's goodbye from me
goodbye
you can do